purple tunnel macular degeneration
social isolation and excellent salary
and back problems if that sounds good to
you might I recommend a career in
programming but how does one actually
learn to code as a complete beginner
well the answer is actually very simple
you need to spend countless hours
staring at the blue light of a computer
screen hitting the keys until something
cool comes out the other side learning
to code was by far the best investment I
ever made in my career and it cost
approximately zero dollars thanks to all
the free stuff on the internet luckily
you don't need to be very smart but you
do need to work hard and put in the
hours required to learn the actual skill
but hours doing what exactly where do I
even start sadly there is no guaranteed
step-by-step program every true coder
will need to go on their own Quest and
slay their own dragons in this video
we'll create seven different road maps
to give you a rough idea of where to
start depending on what it is you
actually want to do with code it's
critical that you find a project that
burns a fire in your loins something to
Anchor you through the extremely
frustrating process of learning a new
skill for me that project was a website
over 10 years ago but nowadays you can
do way cooler stuff like build games iot
devices web mobile and desktop apps
machine learning and data analysis or
code up your own low-level systems if I
had to learn to code from scratch today
here's how I would plan it out let's
start by going down the web development
path maybe your goal is to build the
next Twitter web development might be
the hardest path because there are many
different cats and many ways to skin
them but in a nutshell here's what you
got to do download an editor like the S
code create an HTML file and learn how
the structure of a website works now
create a CSS file and try to make that
structure look good with some custom
styling next you'll need to learn some
JavaScript to make the website
interactive the crazy thing though is
that most people don't use JavaScript by
itself but instead bring in a front-end
framework to build out a UI if your goal
is to get a job learn react because it's
the most popular but if you want to
enjoy yourself you might look into spell
tour view instead that takes care of the
front end but you build an app you also
need a back end the easiest way to do
that is to bring in a back end as a
service like Firebase pocket base or
Super Bass that'll give you user
authentication a database and file
uploads with minimal effort but you'll
also likely need your own custom server
side code and confusingly the easiest
way to do that is with a serverless
platform need to learn some node.js and
understand how HTTP and apis work on the
internet and then finally you can bring
in a meta framework that matches up to
your front-end framework like nexjs
spell kit or next which can put
everything you need together in one
cohesive package and with that we have a
very rough roadmap for web development
but there's about a million different
side quests you could go on along the
way you could also tear up this roadmap
and go use something like Java and
spring boot Ruby on Rails or laravel and
PHP because virtually every programming
language out there can also build web
apps web development is more complex
than any one person's comprehension try
not to get too distracted by hype figure
out a framework you love get involved in
its community and learn the tools that
orbit around it also you could follow
this roadmap step by step or there's
nothing wrong jumping straight into a
framework and trying to learn the
necessary pieces as you go in fact I
kind of prefer the latter chaotic
approach myself the web is the ultimate
platform but some applications are just
better suited for mobile if you want to
build a mobile app on iOS or Android you
can build the highest quality app by
learning how to use use their dedicated
tool chains on iOS that means you'll
need to own a Mac and download the xcode
IDE then learn the Swift programming
language on Android you download Android
Studio then learn Java or the kotlin
programming language most mobile apps
also need a backend and tools like
Firebase or AWS amplify are a great
place to start learning compared to web
development the path forward here is far
less windy however it's still not easy
and if you want to build an app for both
IOS and Android you'll have to learn two
entirely different languages and
platforms as an alternative you can
learn a cross-platform framework such as
flutter with a dart programming language
react native with JavaScript or
microsoft.net framework with c-sharp to
build apps for both IOS and Android from
a single code base although maybe you
don't want a mobile app but rather a
desktop app like you can build Mac OS
apps with swift although you can also
use Swift to build Windows apps at the
same time you can use.net to build
Windows apps and also.net Maui to build
Mac OS apps or maybe you want to build
Linux apps for that there's a toolkit
called gtk that can build native Linux
apps in a variety of different languages
or maybe you want to Target all three at
the same time Frameworks like electron
and Towery allow you to build desktop
apps using JavaScript that run on any
platform if you already know some web
development these can be awesome tools
but if you're starting from scratch you
likely want to choose the platform
you're most comfortable with and start
by building apps for that platform with
its preferred tool chain what's
depressing about app development though
is that it can sometimes feel like we're
building nothing in an infinite void
just a vaporware that will never feel
the touch of a real human but another
path you might take is Hardware maybe
you want to build an iot device a robot
or a flamethrower synchronized to your
guitar plane
for this path you can start building
things with a Raspberry Pi it's just a
tiny computer where you can start
learning the basics of the Linux
operating system once you have it up and
running you can then start learning the
Python programming language python is
the most popular language for beginners
because it's easy to learn and can do
almost anything on Raspberry Pi you can
connect a breadboard to build circuits
then control their behavior with your
python code or another option is to buy
an Arduino which has a microcontroller
that can be programmed with its own C
like language along the way there's a
ton to learn about circuitry and
networking before you eventually connect
your iot device to the cloud at that
point you'll need to learn some back-end
development and protocols like mqtt to
pass messages between your devices
another great place to start learning to
code is by building a game modern
Frameworks like unity and Godot make it
possible for the average person to
develop an awesome game independently
both Frameworks provide an integrated
development environment where you can
drag and drop different game elements
then change their behavior with code
both game engines are based on the
c-sharp programming language but Dill
also has its own purpose-built language
that's a little easier for beginners
either way there's a lot to learn about
game physics in addition to 3D modeling
with topics like shaders meshes Ray
tracing and so on luckily almost
everything you need to learn is
contained within the game engine but
there's also a huge ecosystem of
third-party assets that you can
Implement in your own code so you're not
doing everything from scratch as you
gain more experience you might then
check out Unreal Engine which is based
on the C plus language it's more
challenging as a beginner but is the
engine of choice for many top tier AAA
games one of the most exciting fields to
get into right now though is machine
learning where you can build artificial
intelligence to make yourself obsolete
machine learning is tricky because you
can't just make it happen out of thin
air you need to have a whole bunch of
data first in my opinion the best way to
get started is to participate in data
science competitions on kaggle here you
can obtain real world data and analyze
it with a community of other data
scientists and if you're really good at
it you can actually win a lot of money
before you get to that point though
you'll need to learn a language designed
for scientific computing the most common
options are Julia R and of course python
if you go to python route you'll first
want to learn libraries like pandas to
organize your data matplotlib to
visually analyze the data and scikit
learn to start running some basic
machine learning algorithms on it along
the way you'll need to learn a lot about
math because machine learning is just a
fancy way of doing statistics once you
have the basics down you can then move
into deep neural networks with libraries
like tensorflow and pytorch which are
the tools used to build the most
terrifying modern day AI applications
the final way you might learn to code is
by going straight into systems
engineering when you go to prison the
best way to survive is to find the
biggest guy in there and knock him or
her out on your first day you can take a
similar approach when learning to code
by immediately starting with the C
programming language ECC is the language
used to build almost everything else
like the Mac windows and Linux operating
system kernels and the python
interpreter itself surprisingly though C
is actually a pretty easy language to
get started with it's just missing a lot
of other data structures like a list or
dictionary that you might take for
granted in Python that means you'll have
to implement your own stuff from scratch
lead to understand how low-level memory
management works and how to implement
algorithms that most people only study
just to survive an interview it's a
trial by fire that will make you the
most badass [ __ ] in prison in
reality if you go this route you'll most
likely just get your ass kicked but I
think every developer should try out
prison just a little bit it'll make you
a stronger humble and more well-rounded
developer no matter what you're trying
to code and if you really do enjoy
systems engineering you might learn a
language like rust or C plus if you're a
masochist and with that we have seven
basic road maps that you might use to
learn to code in 2023 but we've barely
scratched the surface here there are
other skills that are Universal to
almost every one of these paths like you
want to learn git and GitHub to Version
Control your software you'll need to
learn Linux and The Bash language for
Shell scripting you should know a thing
or two about networking like how HTTP
and DNS work and how apis are built on
top of them with standards like rest or
PC and graphql truth be told I'm not an
expert in any of this stuff I've crammed
so much stuff into my brain that
whenever I learn something new something
falls out on the other side it's normal
to feel overwhelmed when learning to
code what you want to do is try to get
really good at one thing like become a
top 10 expert in that field it may take
years to get there but if you do it
you'll likely have an awesome job for
the rest of your life learning to code
is a lifelong journey there's no Final
Destination and it can be extremely
frustrating and painful but the reward
for suffering is experience and
experience is what makes you money
thanks for watching and I will see you
in the next one